[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes en automne 2019 un vendredi
matin pas comme les autres
imaginez la femme que vous avez devant
vous maman 40 ans
expert-comptable chef d'entreprise
engagées en politique
cadenasser à d'autres activités du
climat bloquant un pont en plein
centre-ville de Lausanne
nous étions plusieurs centaines ce
jour-là je tenais une banderole action
ou extinction
j'apprends que rien n'a été laissé au
hasard pour préparer cette opération des
dizaines de réunions secrètes avec les
téléphones éteints enfermés dans des
boîtes loin des activistes car nous
savons que certains et certaines d'entre
nous sont sur écoute
ce n'est pas de la paranoïa à l'étranger
les mouvements de désobéissance civile
non violente comme le nôtre sont taxés
d'organisation terroriste
mon ordinateur a même été hacké quelques
temps après cette action
faite c'est mon pseudo je suis prête en
position j'attends les instructions
fourmis réponds tout est prêt départ
dans 3 minutes alors Go avec amour et
détermination
c'est ce genre d'échange que l'on peut
lire sur nos messagerie cryptée et
sécurisé à tel point que les messages
s'autodétruisent au bout de quelques
minutes
mes compagnons d'un jour je ne connais
pas leur vrai nom on se croirait dans un
film et ben non on organise une simple
occupation de l'espace public une
manifestation pour dénoncer l'inaction
climatique mais ensuite on n'aime pas
trop les manifestations
le jour et l'heure précise on est en
Suisse sont annoncés publiquement sur
les réseaux sociaux et dans les médias
le lieu exact reste flou jusqu'à la
dernière minute et alors que la ville
est pleine de force de l'ordre les
activistes telles des commandos de
civils les esquives arrivent sur le pont
s'asseye bloque le trafic pour donc
d’autres amènent une scène de concerts
des toilettes sèches et même un voilier
pour symboliser la galère dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons
c'est la fête sur ce pont on danse on
chante on fait des pique-niques on donne
des conférences des personnalités du
monde scientifique et des prix Nobel
font des discours la police arrive et
nous demande immédiatement de nous
disperser nous et manifestons on reste
assis certaines et certains d'autres
nous portent même une couche prêt à
rester des heures voire des jours nous
sommes déterminés à rester jusqu'à ce
que nous revendications soient entendus
certains passants nous insultent
d'autres nous apportent à boire et à
manger beaucoup s'asseyent avec nous ou
s'arrête pour écouter les conférences
qui expliquent l'urgence de la situation
environnementale et pourquoi nous sommes
ici
dans l'audience je vois un policier ému
aux larmes
dernière sommation de la police si nous
partons pas de dénonciation nous restons
nous sommes déterminés nous n'avons pas
peur
alors nous nous étions bras dessus bras
dessous
solidairement les uns avec les autres et
un par un
les policiers viennent nous déloger on
nous portons par les pieds et par les
mains je me fais un peu molle comme
celle-ci de résistance et de
protestation
prise d'identité on m'embarque dans un
fourgon blindé direction le poste de
police et là
avant de disparaître je vois mes enfants
en pleurs
d'un côté la peur de deux enfants de 3
et 5 ans on voyait leur maman en
détention de l'autre la terreur et
l'angoisse que je ressens à chaque fois
que j'imagine l'avenir que nous leur
laissons température extrême guerre pour
l'eau famine pénurie alimentaire
inondations hors norme
dans notre histoire nous avons connu
bien des tragédies humaines mais aucune
aucune ne s'approche de la catastrophe
que nous nous apprêtons à vivre
une menace existentielle un carnage
climatique un matelas de la souffrance
humaine
tels sont les mots utilisés par le
Secrétaire général de l'ONU qui n'est
pourtant pas une organisation connue
pour être alarmiste ou activiste
lorsqu'il parle de la crise écologique
et du changement climatique il y a deux
semaines encore à la COP 27 il
s'adressait au leader de ce monde avec
ses mots
l'humanité a un choix
coopérer ou périr c'est soit un pacte de
solidarité climatique soit un pacte de
suicide collectif ce cri d'urgence il
raisonne depuis des décennies
c'est ce que moi j'ai découvert il y a
10 ans en lisant les limites de la
croissance c'est un rapport écrit dans
les années 70 et c'était la première
modélisation de l'interdépendance entre
nos systèmes sociaux économiques et
écologiques
et les auteurs étaient formels si nous
persistions sur la trajectoire de
l'époque de croissance exponentielle
notre société
s'effondorait vers 2030 ils avaient
compris que c'était comme continuait de
souffler dans un ballon sans cesse il
finirait un moment donné par exploser et
bien des études récentes ont comparé les
données réelles avec ces scénarios nous
sommes en plein de don
l'effondrement
de nos sociétés vers 2030
nous sommes en 2022
2030 c'est dans 8 ans
à la parution de ce rapport il était
encore possible de réduire notre
consommation de ressources notamment du
pétrole mais nous n'avons rien fait au
contraire nous émissions et notre
consommation n'ont cessé d'augmenter
en 40 ans nous avons causé la
disparition de 70% des vertébrés
pour moi c'est le choc je ressens une
colère face à cette inaction et à ce
destin qui semble inéluctable
puis cette colère se transforme en deuil
et en désespoir
deuil de l'avenir que j'aurais souhaité
espérer avoir pour moi et mes enfants
c'est un point de bascule dans ma vie
qui va déterminer tous mes choix futurs
une fois que je sais je ne peux pas
continuer à vivre comme avant
comme si de rien n'était
alors je quitte mon job confortable et
je pars travailler dans une ONG je
réduis drastiquement mon train de vie et
ma consommation je m'engage activement
dans des associations je me forme à
l'écologie je m'informe je lis des
études scientifiques je participe au
lancement d'initiative populaire je vais
au marché récolter des signatures je
fais des marges pour le climat j'écris
des articles dans la presse je m'inscris
même sur une liste politique sans grand
espoir et à ma propre surprise je suis
élue au législatives de la ville de
Lausanne j'utilise tous les leviers
légaux à disposition je n'arrête pas
mais notre démocratie se heurte à sa
propre lenteur ainsi qu'au million des
lobbies oui en Suisse aussi les lobbies
n'hésitent pas à financer des campagnes
de désinformation pour préserver coûte
que coûte le statut quo de business à
Juju et ce malgré l'accumulation des
preuves scientifiques
en 2002 déjà
Chirac prononçait cette phrase
notre maison brûle et nous regardons
ailleurs
c'était il y a 20 ans nos politiques
savaient mais ils n'ont rien fait ou si
peu encore aujourd'hui leurs yeux sont
rivés sur la croissance le PIB le
pouvoir d'achat ou leur propre élections
des dizaines de milliers de
scientifiques appellent à une
transformation
urgente et drastique de tous les aspects
de nos sociétés
car la science est claire nous pouvons
encore inverser la tendance mais il nous
faut agir de manière immédiate et
radicale
on les écoute pas plus alors après des
années à prêcher dans le désert il
désobéissent eux aussi et ils appellent
à une mobilisation ils appellent à
l'action collective
car seul une porte mobilisation une
mobilisation de masse peut changer le
cours des choses nous avons besoin d'un
milliard d'activistes climatiques d'hyp
petercalmus un célèbre climatologue de
la NASA qui s'est récemment enchaîné
devant une banque d'affaires pour
dénoncer ses investissements dans les
énergies faciles
alors j'entends cet appel et je les
rejoins Je deviens moi aussi une
activiste
car face à l'inertie globale les
mouvements de désobéissance civile non
violente ont eux compris l'urgence je
m'y engage sont pourronter tous mes
autres engagements pour être en parfaite
alignement avec ma conscience et avec ma
compréhension des enjeux
me retrouver entouré de personnes de
tout bord et de toute génération qui
partage mes préoccupations face à
l'avenir me redonne une énergie que
j'avais perdue ma colère se transforme
alors on force et en moteur pour
l'action c'est l'effervescence
collective pour moi c'est la réponse à
l'inaction climatique
car l'histoire montre que toutes les
avancées sociales sont le fruit de
contestation populaire
l'obtention d'une masse critique qui
fait basculer l'opinion publique et
changer les lois et ainsi avoir des
actions politiques fortes notamment
toutes les avancées dans les droits
civiques des minorités ont été obtenues
grâce à la collaboration étroite entre
des mouvements dit plus modérés et un
flan plus radical
mesdames si aujourd'hui vous pouvez
voter c'est qu'un jour des femmes se
sont levées pour bousculer l'ordre
établi avec des actions chocs illégales
au prix de leur liberté pour que les
choses avancent
par exemple le premier mars 1955 Rosa
Parks une afro-américaine de 42 ans
refuse de céder sa place à une personne
blanche dans un bus de l'Alabama comme
la loi le lui demande
cet acte de désobéissance va être
l'élément déclencheur pour l'abolition
des droits des lois de ségrégation
raciale dont les transports publics aux
États-Unis depuis que les premiers
activistes du climat ont mené leur
première action des villes des États ont
déclaré l'urgence climatique
dont les médias on invite des citoyens
et des citoyennes engagés soutenus par
la parole scientifique dans la presse
menstrime on commence à lire des gros
mots comme décroissance ou comme
sobriété
le discours change
en Suisse les lois restent encore figées
pour l'instant
car il est aujourd'hui légal pour une
multinationale de détruire les
conditions d'habitabilité de cette terre
est-ce que c'est légitime
nous actions sont-elles illégales
sont-elles illégitimes elles m'ont déjà
valu deux procès
car lorsque l'état faillit à son rôle de
protection de ses citoyens et de ses
citoyens il échoue dans son rôle
essentiel et il est donc légitime de
désobéir
ce n'est plus seulement un droit mais ça
devient un devoir
nous avons une responsabilité de
désobéir pour protéger la vie pour nous
et pour nos générations futures
nous avons encore une chance de changer
le cours des choses nous pouvons
ensemble créer une société plus sobre
résiliente juste et équitable pour
toutes et tous
je veux faire tout ce qui est possible
pour inverser la tendance changer le
cours des choses pour moi et mes enfants
la maman
qui était assise sur la chaussée elle
tenait une banderole
action ou extinction
moi
j'ai choisi l'action
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]